Hi there, Shankar here. One of the bleak realities of the COVID-19 pandemic is that not every group has been affected equally. Older Americans have suffered more than the young. Residents of some cities and states have faced a higher risk than others. There are also vast racial disparities. There are also vast racial disparities. In Chicago, for example, black people make up 30% of the city's population. They are 56% of the city's COVID-19 deaths. Here in Los Angeles, 16% of deaths are African-American. Only 9% of the population is African-American.
大家好，我是香卡。COVID-19 疫情的一个残酷现实是，并非每个群体受到的影响都是平等的。老年美国人受到的打击比年轻人更大。一些城市和州的居民面临的风险也比其他地方更高。种族之间也存在巨大的差异。种族之间也存在巨大的差异。例如，在芝加哥，黑人占该市人口的 30%。而在该市因 COVID-19 死亡的人数中，黑人占了 56%。在洛杉矶，16% 的死者是非裔美国人。而非裔美国人仅占总人口的 9%。
And this doesn't exist. So I represent that legacy of growing up poor and black in America. And I and many black Americans are at higher risk for COVID. Black Americans are far more likely than white Americans to have contracted the coronavirus or died from COVID-19. Many of the reasons for these disparities reach back to before the pandemic began. There are longstanding inequities in the healthcare system.
而这种情况并不存在。所以我代表了在美国作为穷人和黑人长大的那种历史传承。我和许多美国黑人面临着更高的感染新冠风险。美国黑人感染冠状病毒或死于 COVID-19 的可能性远高于美国白人。造成这些差异的许多原因可以追溯到大流行开始之前。医疗保健系统中长期存在着不平等现象。
In 2019, we talked about a specific source of racial disparities. We also considered an uncomfortable solution. It's a timely topic, and we decided to bring it back today. Here it is. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There is comfort in the familiar. That's why Marlon Wade likes to head over to his local barber shop, wrist action.
在 2019 年，我们讨论了导致种族差异的一个特定根源。我们还探讨了一个令人感到不安的解决方案。这是一个适时的话题，我们决定今天将其重新呈现。就是这样。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。熟悉的事物总能带给人慰藉。这就是为什么马伦·韦德喜欢去他当地的理发店，手腕转动。
I just stop in. It's on MacArthur Boulevard in Oakland, California. He doesn't come for a cut. No here, no here. I just wear the ball here. He comes to shoot the breeze. He points to one of the barbers, who's a friend. That's my son's. God, probably. That's one of my old school teammates.
我只是顺便进去。它位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰的麦克阿瑟大道上。他来这里不是为了理发。这里没有，这里没有。我只是来这里聊聊天。他指着其中一位理发师，那是他的朋友。那可能是我儿子的教父。那是我以前的老校友。
Basically, Marlin likes to hang with people who know and understand him. People he grew up with. Some years ago, when Marlin was in the market for a new doctor, people he grew up with. Some years ago, when Marlin was in the market for a new doctor, he looked for that same feeling of connection. I had various choices. I had like, I had over 20, 20 docks of tattoos from. But once stood out, she was like him, black, and like him, a practicing Muslim. She gets me, I get her. We talk about life, we talk about our religion. You know, if something wrong with me, she gonna let me know.
基本上，马伦喜欢和那些了解他、理解他的人在一起。那些和他一起长大的人。几年前，当马伦在物色新医生时，那些和他一起长大的人。几年前，当马伦在物色新医生时，他在寻找那种同样的连结感。我有很多选择。我有，我有 20 多个，20 多个医生的纹身可以参考。但有一个脱颖而出，她和他一样是黑人，也和他一样是一位虔诚的穆斯林。她懂我，我懂她。我们聊生活，聊我们的宗教信仰。你知道的，如果我有什么不对劲的地方，她会直言不讳地告诉我。
It's the kind of trusting relationship Marlon doesn't believe he'd find in a doctor of a different race. I don't think a lot of these doctors relate to people in my skin color. Like when it comes to heart disease, diabetes. Like a lot of these diseases can be researched and medically something done for it, but at the end of the day, my community not getting that service. A variety of studies do suggest that black men in America often receive inferior care compared to white patients. They have the lowest life expectancy of any
这是一种充满信任的关系，马伦不认为他在一个不同种族的医生身上能找到这种感觉。我不认为很多这些医生能对我有这种肤色的人感同身受。就像心脏病、糖尿病一样。很多这些疾病可以被研究，医学上也能做点什么，但归根结底，我的社区并没有得到那种服务。各种研究确实表明，与白人患者相比，美国的黑人男性往往接受较差的医疗护理。他们在所有主要人口统计群体中的预期寿命最短。他们死去的许多疾病都是慢性的或可预防的。现在，越来越多的研究表明，马伦·韦德在选择医生时可能真的有所感悟。与非黑人医生相比，黑人医生能够更有效地劝说患者接受更多的预防性服务。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们探讨了一种简单但颇具争议的方法，以改善医学、教育和其他领域的治疗效果。我们不禁要问，当追求色盲社会的理想与硬核证据相碰撞时，会发生什么？这些证据表明，不采取色盲政策可能会带来更好的结果。当欧文·加里克还是个住在布朗克斯南部的孩子时，他住在许多亲戚的街对面，其中包括他的鲍比叔叔。
major demographic group. Many of the diseases they are dying from are chronic or preventable. Now a growing body of research suggests Marlon Wade might be onto something in his choice of doctor. The black doctors were able to convince more effectively the patients to take more of the preventative services compared to the non-black doctors. This week on Hidden Brain, we considered a simple but controversial way to improve outcomes in medicine, education and other fields. And we ask, what happens when the ideal of a colourblind society runs into hard evidence that you may get better outcomes by not being colourblind? When Owen Garrick was a kid growing up in the South Bronx, he lived across the street
所以他总是能陪你一起玩的人，去商场，去商店，去某个朋友家，你可以和他一起去游泳。他是一个你可以随时跳上他的车，到深夜任何时候才回来的人，他就是你的借口，对吧？你知道的，妈妈，鲍比叔叔让我一直在外面待到很晚。但当他 66 岁时，鲍比叔叔发现自己患上了晚期前列腺癌。因此，由于癌细胞转移到骨头，他开始感到骨痛，这让他感到了痛苦，这让他去看了医生。然后他被确诊了。这让他去看了医生，然后他被确诊了。
from a bunch of relatives, including his uncle Bobby. So he was the one that you could always hang out with, to the mall, to the store, to some friend's house, you can go swimming with him. He's a guy you can just jump in his car, come back at all hours of the evening, and he was your excuse, right? You know, mom, Uncle Bobby, you know, had me stayin' out all night. But when he was 66 years old, Uncle Bobby found out he was dying of prostate cancer. So he started having bone pain due to the metastasis to his bone, and that brought him in the pain, brought him in. And so then he was diagnosed. He brought him in and so then he was diagnosed.
他在确诊后几个月大概就去世了。在欧文看来，这是一场本可避免的死亡。前列腺癌通常生长缓慢。它很容易被检测出来。他本可以好好活着，并且在自己的社区和家庭中依然非常活跃，但不幸的是，他就是不肯去做预防性服务。欧文说，他家里的许多老年男性也是这样。他们不信任医生，不做预防性护理。这就是这种
He probably died a few months after he was diagnosed. In Owen's opinion, it was a preventable death. Prostate cancer is usually slow growing. It's easy to detect. He could still be very much alive and still very much active in his community and with his family, but unfortunately, wouldn't go in for a preventative services. Owen says many of the older men in his family were the same way. They didn't trust doctors, they didn't get preventative care. This is the kind of
在黑人美国人中一遍又一遍上演的故事。这也是一个反映在残酷统计数据中的故事。黑人男性的平均预期寿命是 72 岁，比白人男性的平均寿命短大约四年。不仅仅是前列腺癌，还有心血管疾病、中风、糖尿病。大多数死亡都是由可预防或慢性疾病引起的。这是欧文想要改变的事情。他是一名医生兼研究员。他经营着“桥梁临床研究”（Bridge Clinical Research）公司。该公司的使命是让医疗系统更好地服务于美国黑人。欧文厌倦了关于美国黑人和医疗保健的坏消息。
story told over and over again in black America. And it's a story reflected in a grim statistic. The average life expectancy of black men is 72 years, about four years shorter than the average for white men. It's not just prostate cancer, it's cardiovascular disease, stroke, it's diabetes. Most of the death is due to preventable or chronic conditions. This is something Owen wants to change. He's a doctor and researcher. He runs bridge clinical research. A company whose mission is to make the medical system walk better for black Americans. Owen is tired of the bad news about black men and health care in America.
他厌倦了谈论健康结果方面的差异。欧文想要的是一个解决方案，一种能让黑人男性，尤其是低收入黑人男性去看医生进行预防性护理的方法。他希望医生能够倾听患者的心声，患者也能够听从医生的建议。因此，欧文和他的研究同事马塞拉·阿尔雄（Marcella Alchon）和格兰特·格拉齐亚尼（Grant Graziani）设计了一项实地研究，试图回答一个简单的问题：如果被随机指派给一名黑人医生，黑人男性会接受更多的预防性护理服务吗？医生的种族是否会产生影响
He's tired of talking about the disparity in health outcomes. What Owen Wands is a fix, a way to get black men, particularly low-income black men, to go to the doctor for preventative care. He wants doctors who will listen to patients and patients who will listen to doctors. So Owen and his fellow researchers, Marcella Alchon and Grant Graziani, designed a field study to try to answer one simple question. Will black men take more preventative care services of their randomly assigned to a black doctor. Is it possible that the race of your physician matters
就你自身的健康而言？为了找出答案，欧文和他的同事在奥克兰租了一家诊所。他们招募了 14 名黑人和非黑人医生在研究期间为诊所工作。至于患者，他们将目光转向了东湾及其周边的跳蚤市场和理发店。就像马伦·韦德喜欢去的“ wrist action”理发店那样的地方。如果你去一家黑人理发店，你会看到各种各样的黑人男性都在那里。
in terms of your own health? To find out, Owen and his colleagues rented a medical clinic in Oakland. They recruited 14 black and non-black doctors to staff the clinic during the study. For patients, they turned to flea markets and barbershops in and around the East Bay. Places like wrist action where Mullen Wade likes to hang out. If you go to a black barbershop, you will have all sorts of black men in the barbershop.
你今天过得怎么样？理发店里的各种黑人男性。你会看到像我这样的人，你会看到我的孩子们在那家理发店，你会看到没有从高中毕业的人以及他们的孩子。第一步是询问这些地方的顾客是否愿意回答一些基本问题。大约有 1300 名男性同意填写一份简短的调查问卷，内容涉及他们的社会经济地位、健康史以及对医疗系统的信任程度。作为对他们努力的感谢，他们获得了现金或免费理发券，以及一张免费健康筛查的优惠券。大约有一半的男性出现在诊所接受了筛查。
How are you doing today? sorts of black men in the barbershop. You'll have folks who like me, you'll have my kids at that barbershop, you'll have folks who didn't graduate from high school and their kids. The first step was asking patrons in these places if they'd answer some basic questions. Some 1300 men agreed to fill out a short survey about their socioeconomic status, health history and level of trust in the medical system. For these efforts, they received cash or a voucher for a free haircut plus a coupon for a free health screening. About half the men showed up at the clinic for that screening.
在检查之前，诊所工作人员向这些男性展示了随机分配给他们的医生的照片。他们还要求他们从一份愿意接受的预防性护理服务清单中进行选择。测量身高和体重以检查身体质量指数（BMI）、血压、总胆固醇以及糖尿病筛查（即糖化血红蛋白 A1C）。起初，这些男性的选择很相似。他们普遍接受了大致相同水平的预防性服务。换句话说，看到医生的照片并没有改变患者对接受哪些服务的决定。通常情况下，这些男性会选择其中的某些服务，但并非全部。
Before they check up, the clinic staff showed the men a picture of the doctor they'd been randomly assigned. They also asked them to select from a list of preventative care services that they'd be willing to receive. Hightened weight to check body mass index, blood pressure, cholesterol, which is total cholesterol and a diabetes screen which is hemoglobin A1C. At first the man made similar choices. They all accepted, generally, the same level of preventative services. In other words, seeing the photos of the doctors did not change patients' decisions about what services to accept. Typically, the men would choose some of the services, but not all.
他们可能会同意检查体重指数和血压，但放弃需要扎针的糖尿病和胆固醇检测。但接下来发生的事情改变了他们的选择。然后医生走进来，说道：“好吧，史密斯先生，您只选择了这三项，您知道的，您只选择了身高体重和血压，我们强烈建议您把全部五项都做了，因为这些都是推荐的，对您的健康都有好处。”正如我所说，一些黑人患者被随机分配接受黑人医生的这些建议，
They might agree to get their body mass index and blood pressure checked, but forego the tests for diabetes and cholesterol that come with a needle stick. But what happened next changed their choices. The doctor then comes in and says, okay, Mr. Smith, you've only selected these three, you know, you've only selected heightened weight and blood pressure, we really recommend that you take all five, because they're all recommended, they're all good for your health. As I said, some of the black patients were randomized to receive this advice from a black doctor,
另一些则接受非黑人医生的建议。医生的种族是否影响了患者的做法？黑人医生能够更有效地劝说患者接受医生的种族是否影响了患者的做法？黑人医生能够更有效地劝说患者接受更多的预防性服务。而且不仅是一点点，是多得多。在让患者测量血压和身体质量方面，黑人医生的成功率比非黑人医生高出约 20%。
some from a non-black doctor. Did the race of the physician affect what patients did? The black doctors were able to convince more effectively the patients to take race of the physician affect what patients did? The black doctors were able to convince more effectively the patients to take more of the preventative services. And not just by a little, by a lot. The black doctors were about 20% more successful than non-black doctors at getting patients to have their blood pressure and body mass measured.
在说服患者进行侵入性检查方面，他们甚至更有效。对于糖尿病和流感疫苗，黑人医生的成功率比非黑人医生高出约 50%。接着是胆固醇筛查的结果。与非黑人医生相比，黑人医生推荐并让黑人男性患者接受胆固醇筛查的能力存在 72% 的差异。72% 的差异。现在，这些结果在现实生活中的意义可能非常重大。例如，高胆固醇会导致心脏病发作、中风。
They were even more effective at persuading their patients to have invasive tests. For diabetes and the flu shot, the black doctors were about 50% more successful than non-black doctors. And then came the cholesterol results. There was a 72% difference in the ability of the black doctor to recommend and have the black male patient take cholesterol screening compared to the non-black doctor. 72% Now the real life implications of these results might be significant. High cholesterol, for instance, can lead to heart attacks, strokes.
如果现实世界中的黑人患者对他们的医生的反应就像研究中的对照组那样，会怎样？欧文·加里克表示，美国黑人和白人在心血管疾病结果方面的差距可能会缩小近 20%。这可能意味着有 20% 的人能够活着看到他们的孙辈从大学和高中毕业，对吧？我是这么想的。
What if black patients in the real world responded to their physicians like the counterparts in the study? Owen Garrick says the gap in the United States between blacks and whites and cardiovascular disease outcomes might shrink by nearly 20%. That could be 20% of the people living to see their grandkids graduate from college in high school, right? That's how I think about it.
这些结果表明，这可能是一种简单、低成本的拯救黑人男性生命的方法。欧文和他的同事们想要弄清楚到底发生了什么。为什么黑人医生如此有效？研究人员认为偏见并未在其中起作用，因为患者对所有医生（无论是黑人还是非黑人）的评价同样高。但随后他们发现了一个线索。这个线索藏在医生关于他们患者的记录中。我们发现，相比非黑人医生，黑人医生实际上写了更多关于患者的记录
These results suggest they might be an easy, low-cost way to save the lives of black men. Owen and his colleagues wanted to understand what was going on. Why were the black doctors so much more effective? The researchers didn't think prejudice was at play because the patients rated all the physicians black and non-black, as equally good. But then they discovered a clue. It was in the notes the doctors had written about their patients. We found that the black doctors actually wrote more notes compared to the non-black doctors
关于他们的患者。而且这些记录通常谈论的是与医疗无关的问题。比如即将到来的婚礼。勇士队会蝉联 NBA 冠军吗？也就是说，是些非医疗问题。黑人医生和黑人患者作为人与人之间建立了连结。他们在谈论家庭、体育、生活。
about their patients. And often those notes talked about their non-health care issues. A wedding is coming up. Will the war is repeat as NBA champions? Like, so non-medical issues. The black doctors and black patients were connecting as human beings. They were talking about family, sports, life.
这种闲聊传递的信息是：我理解你的处境，我倾听你的心声。理发店的马伦·韦德对他的医生也有同样的看法。她懂我，我懂她。我们聊生活，聊我们的宗教信仰。你知道的，如果我有什么不对劲的地方，她会直言不讳地告诉我。欧文的研究是越来越多的研究成果的一部分，这些研究表明，按种族匹配患者和
It's the kind of chitchat that says, I know where you're coming from. I hear you. Marlon Wade from the Barbershop made the very same point about his doctor. She gets me, I get hurt. We talk about life, we talk about our religion. You know, if something wrong with me, she gonna let me know. Owen's research is part of a growing body of work that suggests matching patients and
医生可以在健康结果上产生影响。在另一项研究中，研究人员发现，佛罗里达州被分配给同种族医生的患者在住院期间死亡的可能性降低了 13%。这些结果几乎完全是由与黑人医生相匹配的黑人患者推动的。这项研究对我们的医疗系统、我们的社会以及我们的偏见提出了棘手的问题。这项研究最明确的启示是，热情和富有同理心的沟通至关重要。欧文·加里克认为，或许可以教导医生去弥合他在研究中所观察到的一些差异。因为如果沟通是其机制，你可以训练，或者你应该能够训练
doctors by race can make a difference in health outcomes. In another study, researchers found that Florida patients assigned to physicians of their own race were 13% less likely to die while in the hospital. These results were driven almost entirely by black patients matched with black physicians. The research raises difficult questions about our medical system, our society, and our biases. The clearest takeaway from the research is that warm and empathetic communication matters. Owen Garag believes that doctors might be taught to bridge some of the differences he observed in his study. Because if communication is the mechanism, you can train or you should be able to train
非黑人医生与患者进行更有效的沟通。还有一个更令人畏惧的启示。如果你想在医疗保健领域获得更好的结果，尤其是在最脆弱的患者群体中，拥有更多样化的医生队伍是至关重要的。欧文说，他希望的是让患者拥有选择权。如果他们想看黑人医生，他们可以选择。但目前这往往是不可能的。4% 的医生是黑人，而黑人占美国人口的 13%，因此远未达到代表性比例。值得注意的是，选择权不仅是黑人可能更倾向的事情。在随后的调查中，欧文和他的团队发现，黑人和白人受访者都表示出对同种族医生的偏好。
non-black doctors to more effectively communicate with their patients. There is a more daunting takeaway. If you want better outcomes in health care, especially among the most vulnerable patients, having a more diverse pool of physicians is crucial. Owen says what he wants is for patients to have a choice. If they want to see a black doctor, they can choose one. But right now that's often not possible. 4% of physicians of black, blacks represent 13% of the US population, so not a representation. It's important to note that choice is not just something blacks might prefer. In a follow-up survey, Owen and his team found that both black and white respondents indicated a same race preference.
65% 受访的黑人表示，黑人医生能更好地理解他们的担忧。70% 的白人表示，白人医生能更好地理解他们。欧文研究的第三个启示带有放射性般的争议。鉴于这些结果，我问他，医院和医疗中心是否应该按种族匹配患者和医生，特别是在涉及黑人男性时？欧文对这种需要被视作具争议禁忌的想法提出了质疑。兄弟会和姐妹会是按性别自我选择的。你可以争辩说这是隔离。我不会认为那是隔离，但你知道，有人可能会这么认为，悲观主义者可能会这么认为，
65% of black surveyed said a black doctor would better understand their concerns. 70% of whites said a white doctor would better understand them. There is a third implication of Owen's research, and it feels radioactive. Given the results, I asked him, should hospitals and medical centers match patients and doctors by race, particularly when it comes to black men? Owen challenged the notion that this needed to be a radioactive idea. Ferturneities and sororities self-select by gender. You could argue that that's segregation. I wouldn't argue that that's segregation, but you know someone might, you know, a pessimist might,
而且我认为世上的悲观主义者可能会争辩说，为黑人患者推荐黑人医生就是种族隔离。我不这么看。不过，欧文承认，如果医院刻意将黑人患者引导至黑人医生处，将白人患者引导至白人医生处，他会感到不安。毕竟，我们作为国家为了克服种族隔离斗争了几十年。如果患者来到诊所时被告知“你是黑人，所以我们要把你送到黑人医生那里”，他们会有什么反应？这里确实存在一些紧张关系，对吧？因为我认为这里有两种价值观彼此冲突。我的意思是，其中一种价值观基本上说，你知道，我们本质上都应该平等对待彼此。我们应该融洽相处。我们都应该，你知道，
and I think in the pessimists of the world might argue that recommending black physicians for black patients is segregation. I don't see it that way. Still, Owen acknowledges he would be uncomfortable with the idea that hospitals would deliberately steer black patients to black doctors and white patients to white doctors. After all, we struggled as a nation for decades to overcome segregation. How would patients react if they were told when they showed up at a clinic, you're black, so we're sending you to the black doctor? There is some tension here, right? Because there are two values, I think, that are in conflict with one another here. I mean, there is one value that basically says, you know, we should all essentially treat one another the same. We should all get along well. We should all, you know,
正如马丁·路德·金博士所说，看彼此的品格和能力，而不是看我们的肤色或性别。我的意思是，这是一个理想。而另一个理想是，我们应该相信数据，我们应该相信证据，我们应该遵循证据指引的方向，感觉这两种价值观——遵循证据和数据，以及遵循我们关于社会应有面貌的规范——这两种价值观是冲突的。没错，它们之所以部分冲突，是因为我们并不生活在一个理想的世界里。有些人可能会争辩，世上的怀疑论者可能会争辩说，我们自称生活在一个理想世界中，
as Dr. King would say, look at each other's character and abilities and not the color of our skin or our gender. I mean, so that is an ideal. And the other ideal is we should trust the data and we should trust the evidence and we should follow where the evidence leads and it feels like those two values following the evidence and the data and following this norm that we have about how we'd like our society to be, these two values are in conflict. Right, and they're partly in conflict because we don't live in an ideal world. And some might argue, skeptics of the world might argue that we profess to live in an ideal world,
而我们绝对知道世界并不理想。鉴于此，鉴于你被发到的牌，你所过的主流生活，我们生存的世界，在我们的案例中，你如何才能最好地实现所有人健康状况的改善，特别是在我们的研究中，即黑人男性群体的健康改善。医生的种族这个问题似乎确实管用。而且不仅在医学领域如此。当我们回来时，我们将探讨从教育、零售到银行业等各个领域，按身份匹配人们所产生的结果。
and we know absolutely the world is not ideal. So given that, given the cards your adult, the life you live, the world we exist in, how do you best, in our case, accomplish improved health outcomes for all populations and specifically in our research study, the black male population. And this issue of the race of the doctor seems to work. And it isn't just in medicine. When we come back, the results of matching people by their identities from education, to retail, to banking.
1985 年，田纳西州的研究人员发起了一项大规模实验，以检验班级规模是否会影响学习。当时有大量轶事证据表明，孩子们在小班中表现更好，但没有硬数据来证明这一点。“明星计划”（Project STAR）改变了这一点。从幼儿园到三年级，超过 11,000 名学生被随机分到三个班级规模组别中的一组。研究人员追踪了他们的表现随时间的变化。这项实验现在被认为是开展过的最重要的教育研究之一。它
In 1985, researchers in Tennessee launched a massive experiment to see if class sizes affected learning. There was plenty of anecdotal evidence at the time suggesting that kids did better and smaller classes, but there was no hard data to prove it. Project STAR changed that. More than 11,000 students from kindergarten through third grade were randomly assigned to one of three class size groups. Researchers track their performance over time. The experiment is now considered one of the most important education studies ever conducted. It
表明，较小的班级规模可以显著改善早期学习，特别是对少数族裔学生而言。在此后的几十年里，研究人员也开始意识到，“明星计划”中学生的随机分组可以用来研究别的事情。如果你按班级规模进行随机分配，别的事情。如果你按班级规模进行随机分配，你同时也是在按教师种族进行随机分配。这位是康斯坦丝·林赛（Constance Lindsay）。她是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的教育学教授。她说，这一洞察引出了一条新的研究课题。拥有同种族老师的孩子是否比没有的孩子表现得更好？托马斯·迪（Thomas Dee）是教育研究员，他是第一个以这种新方式分析“明星计划”数据的人。
showed that smaller class sizes led to substantial improvements in early learning, especially for minority students. In the decades since, researchers have also come to realize the random placement of kids in project star could be used to study something else. If you are randomizing by class size, something else. If you are randomizing by class size, you are also randomizing by teacher race. This is Constance Lindsay. She is an education professor at the University of North Carolina in Chapel Hill. She said this insight led to a new research question. Do children who have a teacher of the same race do better than children who don't. Education Research at Thomas D was the first to analyze the project star data in this new way.
如果学生与同种族的老师相匹配，他们的表现会更好吗？2004 年，他发表了他的研究结果。康斯坦丝说，这些结果令人瞩目。如果你是一个黑人学生，并且你有一位黑人老师，平均而言，你的测试成绩会比一个有白人老师的黑人学生更高。这些发现不仅适用于黑人孩子。它们对白人学生同样适用。无论是黑人孩子还是白人孩子，如果他们的老师和他们属于同一种族，他们在数学和阅读成就测试中的表现都会更好。托马斯·迪担心，他的研究结果可能会引发人们呼吁在学校中增加种族隔离。
Did students do better if they were matched with the teacher of the same race? In 2004, he published his findings. Constance says they were striking. If you're a black student and you have a black teacher on average you're going to have a higher test score than a black student who has a white teacher. The findings weren't just specific to black kids. They also held true for white students. Both black and white kids did better on math and reading achievement tests if they had a teacher of the same race. Thomas D. Warrid that his results might cause people to call for increased racial segregation
他觉得那将是一个错误。他首先指出，他的研究结果仅适用于孩子们在“明星计划”实验期间的表现。这些结果并不能预测更长时期的学业成就。其次，他认为最好的启示应该是进行更多的研究。他敦促研究人员继续探索为什么种族动态在课堂上很重要。14 年后，康斯坦丝·林赛和她的同事们正是这样做的。基本上，我们所做的是，我们说，让我们利用能够跨越许多很多年追踪这些学生的事实，看看他们在高中辍学方面会发生什么，
in schools. He felt that would be a mistake. He first noted that his results only apply to how kids were doing during the foyer experiment. The results did not predict achievement over longer time periods. Second, he felt the best takeaway would be more study. He urged researchers to continue exploring why race dynamics matter in the classroom. 14 years later, Constance Lindsay and her colleagues did just that. Basically what we did is we said, let's use the fact that we can follow the students over many, many years and see what happens to them in terms of high school dropout,
他们是否参加了大学入学考试，然后是否进入了大学学习。换句话说，他们试图回答托马斯·迪提出的开放性问题。被随机分到黑人老师班上的黑人儿童在长期来看表现是否更好？他们发现的是，那些早期的互动产生了持久的影响。在我们样本中与黑人老师相匹配的黑人学生，高中辍学的可能性更小，更有可能参加大学入学考试（比如 SAT、ACT），并且更有可能进入大学。
whether they take a college entrance exam, and then whether they enroll in college. In other words, they tried to answer the open question Thomas D had raised. Do black children who were randomly assigned to black teachers perform better over the long term? What they found is those early interactions had a lasting effect. Black students in our sample who were matched to a black teacher were less likely to drop out of high school more likely to sit for college interest exam, so think, you know, SAT, ACT, and then more likely to enroll in college.
黑人学生的成功率随着他们与黑人老师相处的时间逐年增加。花更多时间与黑人老师相处的黑人学生比花较少时间的黑人学生表现得更好。这些结果可能产生巨大的影响。它们表明，种族匹配可能是让更多处于危险中的黑人孩子留在学校并继续接受高等教育的一种方法。当然，田纳西州只是一个州，研究人员希望确保他们研究的不是一个单一州的现象。于是他们转向了北卡罗来纳州。这个州拥有庞大的公立学校
The success of Black students increased with every year they were matched with Black teachers. Black students who spent more time with Black teachers did better than Black students who spent less time. These results could have huge implications. They suggest that race matching might be one way to get more at-risk black kids to stay in school and go on to higher education. Of course, Tennessee is just one state and researchers wanted to make sure they weren't looking at a one-state phenomenon. So they turned to North Carolina. This state has a huge public school
数据库。它包含关于学生的各种信息，包括他们的族裔背景、选修的课程以及多年来各个老师的种族。研究人员再次观察了小学儿童，并随着时间的推移追踪了他们。现在，这些孩子并没有像在田纳西州那样被随机匹配，但他们仍然接触到了黑人老师和非黑人老师。康斯坦丝说，结果说明了同样的故事。有过黑人老师的黑人孩子高中辍学的可能性更小。然后，当你在北卡罗来纳州完成高中学业时，有一份调查问卷需要填写，上面写着：我将上大学，我不会上大学。这基本上类似于一种上大学意向的测量。我们发现，更多与黑人老师相匹配的黑人学生表示希望
database. It contains all kinds of information about students, including their demographics, the classes they've taken, and the race of various teachers over the years. Again, the researchers looked at kids in elementary school and then tracked them over time. Now these kids weren't randomly matched, like they were in Tennessee, but still they had exposure to black and non-black teachers. Constance says the results told the same story. Black kids who'd had black teachers were less likely to drop out of high school. And then when you finish high school in North Carolina, there's a survey you fill out that says, I will attend college, I will not attend college. It's basically like an intent to attend college measure. And we find that more black students who are a batch to black teachers report wanting
上大学。从拥有黑人老师中获益最多的学生是那些最有可能辍学的学生——低收入黑人男孩。北卡罗来纳州的数据显示，如果在小学时有一位黑人老师，这些男孩高中辍学的可能性会降低 39%。39%。康斯坦丝和她的同事们在教育领域看到的情况，正是欧文·加里克在医学领域看到的。种族很重要。现在我们不知道为什么这些黑人老师在他们的黑人学生的生活中产生了如此大的差异，
to attend college. Students who benefited the most from having a black teacher were those most at risk of dropping out low income black boys. The North Carolina data showed that these boys were 39% less likely to drop out of high school if they had a black teacher in elementary school. 39% What constants and her colleagues were seeing in education is what Owen Garrick saw in medicine. Race matters. Now we don't know why these black teachers were making such a difference in the lives of their black students,
但研究人员认为，这可能是多种力量共同作用的结果。其中之一可能是内隐偏见。老师可能怀有对黑人学生产生负面影响的无意识偏见。这导致他们，你知道的，可能无法为诸如天才班之类的项目识别孩子，或者实施更严厉的纪律惩罚。康斯坦丝说，黑人老师也为黑人学生充当了强大的榜样。你知道的，一个受过大学教育的成年人存在于
but the researchers think a variety of forces might be at work. One could be implicit bias. Teachers may hold unconscious prejudices that negatively affect black students. That prevent them from, you know, maybe identifying kids for things like gifted programs or enacting harsher discipline punishments. Constance says black teachers also service powerful role models for black students. The presence of, you know, a college educated adult
你的生活中会产生影响。还有一种被称为文化能力的东西。也就是说，如果你有一种共同分享的文化东西，老师就能更好地解读行为。这在纪律领域似乎尤其如此。在另一项研究项目中，康斯坦丝和她的同事发现，黑人男孩有时在学校惹麻烦的一个原因是研究人员所说的“蓄意抗拒”（Willful Defiance）。蓄意抗拒就是我跟老师争论，你知道的，也许我顶嘴或类似的事情，然后你就得去校长办公室。那么你对蓄意抗拒看到了什么？所以我们看到，当你有一位黑人老师时，蓄意抗拒的下降幅度是巨大的。但正如美国缺乏黑人医生一样，也缺乏黑人老师。在全国范围内，中小学的老师绝大多数是白人，尽管学生中的种族多样性在不断增加。例如，在北卡罗来纳州的数据中，无论是长期研究还是我所做的纪律研究，都有超过 50% 的黑人学生从未有过黑人老师。
in your life makes a difference. And then there's what's called cultural competence. Which is that teachers are able to read behavior better if you sort of share, you know, if you have cultural things that you share in common. This seems especially true in the area of discipline. In another research project, Constans and our colleagues have found that one reason black boys sometimes get into trouble at school is because of something researchers call Willful Defiance. Willful Defiance is I get into an argument with the teacher and you know, I maybe I talk back or something along those lines
在非常个人的层面上，康斯坦丝深知黑人老师能在学生身上留下持久的印象。因为我的祖母曾是华盛顿特区公立学校的一名老师，时间非常长。康斯坦丝将她描述为一个“温暖的严师”。这是一种会让你对应该做的事情负责，但又以一种温暖的方式来做这件事的人。她的名字叫梅·威尔逊（May Wilson）。梅·威尔逊。嗯，与她打交道时，她很严厉，维持着秩序，她保持着一个有条理的课堂。她才是老板，你知道的。
and then you have to go to the principal's office. And so what do you see with Willful Defiance? So we see that the drops in Willful Defiance are huge when you have a black teacher. But just as there's a shortage of black doctors in America, there's also a shortage of black teachers. Nationwide, teachers in elementary and secondary schools are overwhelmingly white, despite growing racial diversity among students. So for example, in the North Carolina data, both in the long-term study and in the discipline study that I have, over 50% of the black students never have a black teacher.
这位是唐纳德·威廉姆斯（Donald Williams）。他已年近古稀，几乎一生都在华盛顿特区度过。在 20 世纪 70 年代初，唐纳德是邓巴高中（Dunbar High School）的一名学生，这所学校培养了几代非裔美国人学生。这就是梅·威尔逊教书的地方。唐从一本旧年鉴中指着年轻时的自己，他是邓巴高中的明星足球运动员。这里我在阻截，那里我在带球跑，那里我在带球跑，那里我完成了擒抱。唐的大部分高中记忆都围绕着足球展开，除了那个他从未忘过的班主任梅·威尔逊。
On a very personal level, Constance knows well the lasting impression a black teacher can leave on students. Because my grandmother was a teacher here in DC Public Schools for a very long time. Constance describes her as a warm, demander. This is someone who is sort of hold you accountable for the things that you should be doing, but does it in a warm fashion. Her name was May Wilson. May Wilson. Well, dealing with her, she was stirring, kept an order, she kept an orderly class from. She was the boss, you know.
她大概一米六五，但她的气场比那更强大。她不容许任何胡闹。你知道的。你知道的。她就像你在外地的母亲，但她不吃那一套。她不走任何捷径。唐说，梅·威尔逊身上有一种特质，能让你全神贯注。也许是她穿的剪裁考究的西装，或者是她那种权威的气质。她看起来总是干练职业。她看起来总是干练职业。
This is Donald Williams. He's in his late 60s and has lived nearly all his life in Washington, DC. In the early 1970s, Donald was a student at a school that has educated generations of African-American students, Dunbar High School. This is where May Wilson taught. From an old yearbook, Don points to his younger self, a star football player at Dunbar. Here I was blocking, there I was running with the football, there I was running with the football, there I got tackles. Most of Don's memories from high school revolve around football, except for that home room teacher, May Wilson, whom he's never forgotten.
她从不穿夜总会那种裙子或类似的东西来。她看起来总是很专业。所以这是你从她身上看到的另一个信息，她一直在坚持，她坚守守时的规则，做你需要做的事情，不为在公共场合无法控制自己而感到自豪。她教给的功课最终深入人心，成了唐的人生信条。我问他，梅·威尔逊是黑人，这对他在是否有影响？他告诉我，这个问题根本不用想。是的，当然有影响。作为一个黑人小孩。当你看到一个和你处于同样职位的人时，你更能产生共鸣。
She's like five, five, four, but her demeanor was bigger than that. She didn't take a lot of nonsense. You knew it. You knew it. She's like your mother away from home, but she didn't take any stuff. She didn't cut any corners. Dawn says there was something about May Wilson that made you pay attention. Maybe it was the Taylor Scott suit she wore or her air of authority. She always looked business. She always looked business.
因为如果你不是黑人，你就无法理解我在说什么。你可以这么说，因为这是正确的事。得了吧，唐，哦，你不会的。你绝对不可能知道，因为你不是黑人。正确的事。得了吧，唐，哦，你不会的。你绝对不可能知道，因为你不是黑人。唐对他的足球教练也有同样的感受。他说，共同的身份往往会带来信任。就像我说的，一个孩子需要看到一个曾经经历过那种处境的人。当你已经拥有一切时，说这些话很容易。一个富人很容易叫你存钱。他有钱。一个富人怎么能告诉一个穷人发生了什么，生活是怎么回事？那必须是一个知道门道的人，是一个黑人，是经历过这一切的人。
She never came in a nightclub dress or something like that. She always looked professional. So that's another message that you saw in her that she was sticking, she stick to the rules of being on time, doing things that you need to do, not being proud of controlling yourself in public. Her lessons ultimately stuck and became life lessons for dawn. I asked him if it made a difference to him, that May Wilson was black. He told me the question was a no-brainer. Yes, of course it made a difference. It's a black kid. You can relate better when you see someone in the position that you're in.
你知道的，你必须，然后你知道那是他的入场券，那是他的动力，向你展示事情是可以做到的。给学生一种感觉，即他们被那些能够说“这是一个坏想法”的老师所理解，但如果你退一步看，将这个想法付诸实践会遇到与历史、政治和观感相关的各种问题。我问了康斯坦丝·林赛关于这方面的问题。假设你是一所学校的校长，你的二年级有一个黑人老师，并且你假设，二年级的五个平行班里散落着 15 名黑人学生。
Because if you're not black, you can't understand what I'm saying. You can say it because it's the right thing. Go on, it's, oh you don't. You couldn't possibly know because you're not black. the right thing. Don, it's, oh you don't. You couldn't possibly know because you're not black. Don has the same feeling about his football coaches. He says shared identity often led to trust. Like I said, a kid needs to see someone who's been there. It's easy for you to talk it when you got it. It's easy for a rich man to tell you to save your money. He got money. How can a rich man tell a poor man what's going on, what life is about? It's got to be someone that knows the avenues to go to the someone that's black, that's been through it.
你会把这所有 15 个学生都分给那个黑人老师吗？我可能不会这样做。如果我在这特定的一组 15 人中有特别处于不利地位的学生，我可能会。我也可能会探索让老师们共同教学的方法，以便所有这 15 个学生都有机会与这位老师互动，但我绝对不主张将他们隔离到一个班级里。为什么不呢？你的数据显示这样是行之有效的。数据显示这样确实有效。
You know, you got to, and then you know that's his ticket, that's his motivation there to show you was how it can be done. Giving students the feeling that they are understood by their teachers who can say this is a bad idea but if you zoom out putting this idea into practice runs into all sorts of problems related to history, politics, and optics. I asked Constance Lindsay about this. Let's say you're the principal of a school and you have one black teacher in second grade and you have, let's say, 15 black students spread across five sections of second grade.
但我想我们都同意种族隔离是不好的。但我想这正是让这篇论文变得非常非常棘手的地方，它实际上表明，一件我们认为好的事情可能会产生一个并不是那么好的结果。没错。没错。所以我想如果你拿枪指着我的头，对我说我必须在隔离学生和确保学生有一位黑人老师之间做出选择，我会选择让他们有一位黑人老师。所以你实际上会把学生分到同一个班里？如果你
Would you assign all those 15 students to the black teacher? I probably would not do that. If I had students that in that particular set of 15 that were particularly disadvantaged, I might. I might also explore ways in which teachers could co-teach so that all of those 15 students would have the opportunity to interact with that teacher, but I definitely wouldn't advocate sort of segregating them into one class. Why not? That's what your data show works. That is what the data show works.
说我必须的话。不，我想我问你的不是我是否必须这样做，而是你知道的，如果你看了数据，发现你将学生的胜算提高了 10%、15%、甚至 20%，而你却没有做那件能将他们的胜算提高 10%、15%、20% 的事，我的意思是，这是不道德的。你可以这么说。你可以这么说。我的意思是，如果我是一个黑人男孩的家长，而学校里只有一个黑人男老师，我会去告诉校长把我的孩子分到他的班里。有一些证据表明，我们在医学和教育中看到的种族匹配效应也会出现在其他领域。
But I think we agreed that segregation is bad. But I think this is what makes the paper really, really tricky, which is it's actually suggesting that something that we thought was a good thing might have an outcome that is not such a good thing. That's right. That's right. So I guess if you held a gun to my head and you said I had to pick between segregating students and making sure that students had a black teacher, I would pick that they had a black teacher. So you actually would put the students in the same class there? If you
在天普大学（Temple University），德里克·艾弗里（Derek Avery）和他的同事发现，与同种族销售代表互动的零售店顾客拥有更高的满意度。在少数族裔占顾客群体比例更大的地区，情况尤其如此。哥伦比亚大学的雷蒙德·菲斯曼（Raymond Fisman）在印度进行的一项研究中发现，银行家与顾客之间的族裔和宗教匹配提高了贷款偿还的可能性。它还降低了贷款成本，因为银行认为放贷的风险较低。其他研究人员观察到，性别可以起到类似于种族或宗教认同的作用。
said I had to. No, I guess what I'm asking you is not so much whether I have to, but you know, if you looked at the data and said that you are improving the odds of students by 10, 15, maybe 20 percent, and you did not do that thing that could improve their odds by 10, 15, 20 percent, I mean, that is immoral. You could say that. You could say that. I mean, if I were a parent of a black boy and there was one black male teacher in the school, I would go tell the principal to assign my child to him. There is some evidence that race matching effects we see in medicine and education also show up in other spheres.
明尼苏达大学的布拉德·格林伍德（Brad Greenwood）发现，如果医生是女性而不是男性，佛罗里达州有更多的女性心脏病发作幸存者。马萨诸塞大学的社会心理学家尼兰贾娜·达斯古普塔（Nilanjana Dasgupta）发现，当微积分课堂上有女教授而不是男教授时，女学生对科目的参与度更高当微积分课堂上有女教授而不是男教授时，女学生对科目的参与度更高。仅仅有一位女教授，最终会让女性觉得她们在课堂上会表现得更好，从而让她们感到更自信，让她们觉得比由男教授讲授相同课程材料、相同考试、相同教学大纲时更关心数学。相同课程材料、相同考试、相同教学大纲时由男教授讲授。这很重要，因为微积分通往女性目前代表性不足的数学和科学领域学位和职业的门户课程。
At Temple University, Derek Avery and his colleagues found that customers at a retail store who interacted with sales agents of the same race had higher levels of satisfaction. This was especially true in areas where racial minorities were a larger share of the customer base. Columbia University's Raymond Fisman found in a study conducted in India that ethnic and religious matching between bankers and customers increased the likelihood of loans being repaid. It also lowered the cost of loans because banks perceived there was a lower risk in lending money. Other workers observed that gender can act in similar ways to racial or religious identification.
从所有这些例子中可以得出三个教训。首先，我们确实需要来自不同种族、不同背景的医生、老师、贷款专员和店员。这可以产生切实且可测量的结果。第二个教训是，如果我们想被在某些方面与我们不同的人理解，这将需要付出努力。你不能仅仅假设你的工作仅仅以授课或诊断患者开始并结束。
Brad Greenwood at the University of Minnesota found that more women in Florida Survived a heart attack when their doctor was a woman rather than a man At the University of Massachusetts social psychologist Nilanjana Daskup that has found that female students in calculus classes were more engaged in the subject when they had a female professor were more engaged in the subject when they had a female professor rather than a male professor. Just having a female professor ends up making women feel they'll do better in the class, so making them feel more confident, making them feel that they care more about math than when the same course material, same exam, same syllabus, is taught by a male professor. course material, same exam, same syllabus, is taught by a male professor. This is important because calculus is a gateway class to degrees and careers in math and science where women are currently underrepresented.
明尼苏达大学的布拉德·格林伍德发现，在佛罗里达州，当女患者的主治医生是女医生时，她们的心脏病发作存活率要高于男医生。马萨诸塞大学的社会心理学家尼兰詹娜·达斯古普塔发现，微积分课堂上的女生在拥有女教授而不是男教授时，对这门学科的投入度更高。仅仅因为有一位女教授，就会让女性觉得她们在这门课上会表现得更好，从而让她们更有自信，觉得教授比由男教授讲授相同课程内容、相同考试、相同教学大纲时更关心数学。这很重要，因为微积分是通往数学和科学领域学位和职业的门户课程，而女性目前在这些领域中代表性不足。
There are three lessons from all these examples. The first is that we really need doctors and teachers and loan officers and store clerks from different races and different backgrounds. It can have tangible and measurable outcomes. The second lesson is that if we want to be understood by people who are different from us in some way, it's going to take work. You can't just assume that your job begins and ends with teaching a course or diagnosing the patient.
从所有这些例子中可以得出三个教训。首先，我们确实需要来自不同种族和不同背景的医生、教师、信贷员和店员。这会产生切实且可量化的结果。第二个教训是，如果我们想被在某些方面与我们不同的人理解，这需要付出努力。你不能仅仅假设你的工作仅仅始于并止于教授一门课程或诊断一个病人。
You have to make a connection with the human being across from you. The final lesson has to do with the seemingly contradictory effects of diversity. In an earlier episode of Hidden Brain, the Edge Effect, we talked about how diversity boosts creativity and innovation. By contrast, here we've seen how connecting with people who I like us can produce better outcomes. One explanation for this contradiction lies in what you are trying to achieve. You want novelty and creativity? Those flourish from bringing together different perspectives. But if you want trust and communication, those come easier when we have things in common. This week's episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Path Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Laura Quarelle, Thomas Liu,
你必须与你面前的人建立联系。最后一课与多样性看似矛盾的影响有关。在《隐藏的大脑》早期的一集《边缘效应》中，我们讨论了多样性如何促进创造力和创新。相比之下，在这里我们已经看到与喜欢我们的人建立联系如何能产生更好的结果。对这种矛盾的一种解释在于你试图实现的目标。你想要新颖性和创造力？那些因汇聚不同的观点而蓬勃发展。但如果你想要信任和沟通，当我们有共同点时，这些会更容易实现。本期节目由珍妮·施密特和帕斯·沙尔制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩剪辑。我们的团队包括劳拉·夸雷尔、托马斯·刘、
Kat Shuknecht and Lushik Waba. Our unsung hero this week is Jeff Rogers. Jeff runs two of our sister NPR shows, The Ted Radio Hour and How I Built This. He played an early role in helping get hidden brain off the ground. He's also the kind of person you want to have when things are changing quickly around you. Jeff can be coach, friend, and taskmaster. He has an uncanny ability to stay calm, which is why when many people say they have a problem, they also say,
卡特·舒克内奇和卢希克·瓦巴。我们本周的无名英雄是杰夫·罗杰斯。杰夫负责我们的两个 NPR 姊妹节目《TED广播小时》和《我是如何建立这个的》。他在帮助《隐藏的大脑》起步方面发挥了早期作用。他也是那种在你周围事物迅速变化时你希望拥有的人。杰夫可以成为教练、朋友和工头。他有一种不可思议的保持冷静的能力，这就是为什么当许多人说他们有问题时，他们也会说，
I'm sure Jeff can help with that. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If this episode reminded you of someone who is connected in a meaningful way with you, whether that's in the classroom, the doctor's office, or at work, please share this episode with that person. Tell them the impact they had on your life. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我确信杰夫能帮上忙。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在脸书和推特上找到我们。如果这一集让你想起了一个与你有过有意义联系的人，无论是在教室、医生办公室还是在工作场所，请与那个人分享这一集。告诉他们对你生活的影响。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这是 NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。